[Music]
do you encounter a lot of people who are
pissed at you to this day whether it's
the guy that says it on Twitter or
Instagram or Facebook or the guy that
wants to say it in person or to whoever
the people are in this building that
said don't have them on you know what I
say yeah I understand right I totally
get it the vehement denials and the way
that I went about defending myself buddy
if you could the ultimate Lance
Armstrong torture is you put him in
front of a laptop
pull up YouTube and make him watch some
of those press conferences where you
denied B yeah yeah there's such dick and
if somebody were to come up to me and I
wouldn't wherever an airport a bike race
a Vulcan in New York City I'd shake
their hands that I totally understand
and I'm sorry do you think that's why
people are so pissed because of the
vehement denial I think they can get
their mind around the doping right but
they can't they can't excuse at least
yet or maybe some it worth this process
but the way I acted was was by you know
by far the worst part